hey everybody welcome to channel
awesomes orbit report your source for
everything happening around the world in
pop culture and entertainment
I'm Heather Ruth and mi anna-wade and
this is your news for Monday August 7
first up we have to talk about the new
fasting announcement of Australian
actress Tegan cross as raven in the new
DC series labelled simply tiny the only
other two characters that have been
confirmed on this show so far our
Starfire and Dick Grayson Robin yeah so
we still don't have any news about
whether Beast Boy or cyborg is going to
be in the show and it'll be interesting
to see if they replace cyborg given that
now he's a part of the Justice League so
does he even have time to deal with the
Titan time and that's I know exactly
we're just going to have to wait and see
until 2018 which is when this show is
supposed to drop on PCs streaming
service right whatever they're going to
call that yeah at some point right
people in other superhero TV show news
Inhumans release an extended clip it's
just Medusa and Maximus talking and
Sevilla honest it wasn't all that
exciting although we did just to see
Medusa's hair in action a little bit
more some of the CGI is a little off and
some of the first reviews that are
coming in right now are not saying that
it's great which is really unfortunate
although we don't quite want to pass
judgment yes that's right we all have
bad hair days girl at CLU mine isn't
because I have a restriction on my
budget and CGI bells but you know you do
you variable stuff that we can see and
then it's IMAX theatres for the first
episode on September 1st when I believe
drops on September 23rd 25th something
around there
and later this fall on October 11th
we're going to get the premiere of mr.
robot is season 3 which I'm very much
looking forward to especially after that
trailer drop nice job it looks amazing I
don't even watch the show but I would be
all about it like I'd want to go binge
the rest of it right now
exactly and you can because the first
two seasons are chock full of stuff but
we got a bit of a identity crisis on our
hands on the end of season 2 so I'm
looking forward to how they're going to
do that what's going on I don't know I
don't want to give away too much because
it's nothing but spoilers on this show
but I just have to tell you if you don't
watch it go watch it now just in time
for season 3
No will do well in movie news Pacific
Rim uprising has been pushed back after
its original release date was February
23rd 2018 and now they just pushed it
back one month to March 23rd 2018 and
I'm hoping this doesn't mean anything
too bad for the franchise
I assume it's just post-production issue
yet robots hopefully yeah yeah to make
it look nice should I buy this make your
time you make it look nice and pretty I
will be here to watch it yeah right I
was actually a fan of the first movie I
know it was kind of split on that but I
am just a huge fan in general of giant
robots so I am excited for it and
speaking of giant robots
Voltron season 3 just dropped on Netflix
this week and I cannot wait to binge it
if you haven't checked it out you
totally should on that front
it's all on Netflix it's a great
animated series as the original was and
it's a great fun family-friendly show so
you can sit down and watch it with your
kids but also really enjoy it there's
some good writing performances and
complex characters for a kids show I'll
be honest I'm just here for the Legos
yeah so excited about that they're
coming out with the 80s style Voltron
Legos and we cannot wait to build me
some robot definitely gonna buy that
oh yes if you need something else's
dream while you're building your Legos
don't worry Netflix has you covered with
another season ously that
drop a hot American summer that is and
this is the summer camp ten years later
and so they've all met up on a Tuesday
so those are kind of reminisce about old
times which is hilarious because old
times words last season at the beginning
of summer camp and anyways if you
haven't seen it go watch it it's
hilarious
very funny comedy and I like anything
with Amy Poehler let's be real also adam
scott and amy poehler a little bit of
perks in recognition
I've got supposedly playing Bradley
Cooper's character who is now in a
Bradley Cooper couldn't be in it so his
character got a nose job supposedly is
what we're supposed to believe from the
last trailers though it sounds hilarious
and I can't wait to finish mentoring at
that you can look forward you already
now on Netflix if you also really like
something in general don't worry even
got me covered in early 2018 they just
announced that they're going to be
releasing the nostalgic summer camp
reality kid show known as bug you yes
I'm excited about it they apparently
just wrapped up they're wrapping up
filming in August like right now so
it'll be released in early 28th right
right so I'm looking forward to that
that's reality show for kids is
something that's not really going on
right now so why not we'll see how
wholesome this version is in the
trainings but who knows it sounds like
an old version kids please bear all on
their telephones or cellular telephones
just Caxton each other and the bunk man
speaking of nostalgia here The Karate
Kid was just announced to be in
production for a sequel that's going to
be on YouTube red so it's going to be a
TV series I see I do too that features
some of the same actors from the
original of Daniel the actors coming
back to play him and Johnny as well and
it focuses on Johnny who is down and out
which apparently happens when you're a
jerk see they don't succeed in life
everyone
that's right doctor so he was like he
decided to reopen the Cobra Kai dojo and
it rivals Daniels already cry
Jojo and apparently hi-c
thank you yeah David knows which there's
a common comedy uh-huh a 30-minute
comedy so we're not sure yet if it's
going to be a sitcom right with a in
studio audience and all of that but
think me a little uncertain for the
Burton movie isn't necessarily a comedy
I mean it's got funny bits in it but
it's kind of more of just an uplifting
family film so yeah it'll really be
interesting to see the direction that
they're going to take with this really
not sure can I get a laugh track over my
sweet sweet crane move - crazy you guys
you found it I found your tagline
although they are supposedly going to
deal with the fact that mr. miyagi is
gone in that sound hilarious right
I guess well he does it does it so
Daniel is supposedly in conflict losing
his way because he doesn't know what to
do without his mentor mr. Miyagi
but right and so now the latest credited
with Ben Smith is no longer in this
uniform I guess we're not really sure
how I can ignore it
we're gonna see it like well be real it
makes them for YouTube read and
streaming services that like it to bring
big-name shows to their streaming
services because that brings my
subscribers so I totally get it but
we'll see mm-hmm yeah what was that the
same
speaking of feeling old because things
are old now happy sweet 16 to Princess
Diaries ooh yes don't think we forgot
about that sequel that we're supposed to
be getting Princess Diaries 3 where is
that I mean it's supposedly it was grass
that's right Anne Anne Hathaway's on
board Oh
whatever happened to that hunky boy that
she was into uh Chris Pine what's he
doing nowadays
he's probably available
yeah yeah it's not doing anything big
lastly something else that I'm really
that we're really looking forward to is
an award-winning anime called in this
corner of the world is going to be
released in select us beaters this week
August 11 and this movie like I said is
award-winning it's about a family trying
to survive in Japan during World War two
so it's kind of like a slice of life
showing what people in Japan went
through during as an average citizen
during World War 2 and in fact the clip
that we got from it shows the main
heroine collecting different things like
dandelion roots and wild grasses to help
expand the rations that they were given
so it's supposedly very touching and
heartfelt although it does take place in
Hiroshima Prefecture so I'm a little
worried that there's not a happy ending
and all there obviously I'll be seeing
it it sounds beautiful looks awesome so
yeah but we're looking forward to that
okay so that's all we have for this week
if we left out anything let us know in
the comments down below or if there's
something else that you're looking
forward to specifically from what we
talked about let us know
Heather is there anywhere on fishing
together of course a home you can find
me on Twitter at Heather Ruth or
Instagram at Ace roots and I've been
doing more streaming on my twitch
channel you can find me at twitch.tv
slash how their roofs and keep an eye
out because sometimes this weekend
hopefully I'm going to be streaming
Season 2 episode 1 of the new Batman
telltale series which looks awesome I'm
hyped
you should be hi come join me that's
right she's super fun to watch on Twitch
she recently just screamed portal delt
which is super fun to watch you jump in
okay don't worry if I ever twitch it's
going to be for the Kingdom Hearts game
which we saw yes footage at at e3 so I'm
looking forward to some of those worlds
and then key boys maybe a frozen cable
is what what what people would you have
with no comments down below
she's going to follow me on social media
I'm almost cross-platform awesome Ayanna
now on Facebook time
wait otherwise and find me on Instagram
Twitter snapchat all those good places
has awesome
Ayana so come talk to me about what
you're said about for the week anything
else what if no one comes down below
otherwise me at audit report will be
Samuel
[Music]
you